tras varios meses de lucha con Kenia
finalmente es el presidente
el nuevo presidente de la unión africana
esta decisión anunciada Hace unos días
ha dado mucho que hablar en los pasillos
de la unión africana ya que es la
primera vez que un país con tan poco
poder diplomático presidir a la unión
africana algunos observadores que sonán
la capacidad del nuevo presidente para
hacer frente a los diversos retos de
este año la inseguridad alimentaria va
en aumento y el continente sigue siendo
el lugar de muchos conflictos por su
parte su predecesor magistral el
presidente de senegal tuve en balance
desigual y materia de paz y seguridad
con dos golpes y estado una presencia
insuficiente según los expertos en la
crisis entre la República democrática
del Congo irwanda y también sobre la que
son de los soldados marfileños
he retenido y Mali pero a pesar de todas
estas dudas el presidente conmorando ha
dado posesión de su cargo con orgullo
esa mañana Mientras tanto Argelia
Marruecos Egipto y Libia preparando ya
su candidatura para 2024